is cancel culture real the left
says absolutely not you crazy
conservatives
the culture that we're living in right
now is a consequence culture
of accountability where people are being
held responsible for their actions and
that's a very good thing that's a very
conservative thing
levar burton the host of reading rainbow
among other tv shows
he's sick and tired of healing hearing
all this talk about
cancer culture in terms of cancer
culture
i i i think it's misnamed that's a
misnomer i think we have a
consequence culture um and that
consequences are finally encompassing
everybody
in the society whereas um they haven't
been
ever in this country so um i think i
think that
there there are good signs that are
happening in the culture right now
and i think it has everything to do with
a new awareness on people who were
simply unaware
of the real nature of life in this
country
for people who have been othered since
this nation began
so lavar burton is half right he's not
even half right he's a quarter right
some people are being held to
consequence in this country
but a lot of times they're not being
held to consequence for things they
ought to be held to consequence for
and if we've learned nothing for the
past year and a half
it's that a whole lot of people who go
out and pillage
and burn and loot and steal and even
murder
are not being held to consequence at all
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jay hartman who
says
the compelled speech pronouns thing
reminds me of the mask persuasion it's
not for you
it's for them don't be selfish just
repeat
lies with us and engage in superstitious
nonsense
because it's polite this is true it's
all about
this emotional blackmail to say no it's
about it's about them
don't be mean don't be selfish just put
the donut on your head and jump
up and down hey just come on just
humiliate yourself
and say that up is down and black is
white and east is west because that's so
polite because lies are so polite
lies are not polite the truth is polite
the truth will set you free
lies very very disrespectful and cruel
how are you going to find out the truth
well one great way check out
the great courses plus with a library of
over 13 000 audio and video lectures
there are
so many topics to explore on the great
courses plus
and with the great courses plus app you
can watch from your phone or tablet or
even stream them to your tv and you can
start on one and go to the other one
because
people are very busy maybe you're in
your car for a little bit then you go
home then you're sitting up with the
baby
i'm just describing my afternoons now
you can really make this a very
productive time for you
i would highly recommend the brand new
course the great revolutions
of modern history i gravitate a lot
toward the history courses
on the great courses plus but there's
also a ton of very practical stuff
in all sorts of fields i would highly
recommend you start making really really
good
use of your time what are you waiting
for sign up for the great courses plus
today
right now you can sign up for the
quarterly plan to get an extra month
for free just visit my special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles do not miss out on this sign up
and redeem your free month right now at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles levar burton's take here is not
getting enough
traction but it's what the left has been
saying for a long time and i gotta tell
you you know that i have a very
different view on cancel culture than a
number of other conservatives
a lot of other conservatives say that
cancel culture is bad
because it's censorship and we're free
speech absolutists
and you should be able to say whatever
you want without any consequence
whatsoever
and i don't think that's true i think
that when the left says
that canceling is about consequences
that's a very good thing
when the left says that in the 1950s
conservatives canceled communists i
think that's a very good thing
i am all for cancelling certain people
who are trying to upend our culture
sign me up where can i do that the
problem with this current culture
is not that communists are being
canceled
it's that anti-communists are being
canceled it's not that some people are
being
shut up or some people are being
ostracized
for abhorrent views it's that people are
being ostracized for holding perfectly
ordinary views
they're being ostracized for waving the
american flag that's the problem the
problem here
is the substance this is the central
issue
that conservatives get wrong which
coincidentally i talk about at great
length in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
people who are doing very bad things are
not being held to consequence at all
case in point black lives matter just
came out
and effectively endorsed makia bryant's
stabbing her this young woman that she
was living with
which was the cause of her being shot by
that cop blm
just tweeted out quote makia bryant
we say her name another black life
stolen
but we refuse to define or remember
makia by her final moments
we uplift celebrate and honor this black
child for what she loved
doing her hair making tick tocks having
fun
just being a teen rest in power queen
makia bryant whatever else you want to
say it's a sad thing when people go down
a bad path
even if they get their comeuppance it's
a sad thing to watch it happen
makia bryant's life was not stolen her
life
was forfeited she forfeited her life
when she went in and got that knife and
tried to plunge it into that other girl
that was when that cop did the right
thing
by killing her by shooting her to
neutralize the target
and in so doing killing her
she just she was doing what she loved
if she had not loved stabbing people if
she had not loved committing this
violence
she would be alive today is it a sad
thing that she went down that bad path
of course that's a sad thing yep fallen
world
we refuse to define or remember makia by
her final moments you see this what
they're really saying is
we refuse to define mckee obrien by
the act that got her killed namely
trying to stab this girl
we're going to reframe what happened
if makia bryant was killed because she
stabbed a girl that's totally just
if makia bryant was killed because she
liked making tick-tock videos and having
fun well that's not just at all
they are reframing the situation here
just like the
project reframes american history
this is it's the same argument as the
1619 project
the the author of which gleefully took
credit for the 2020 riots all around the
country
the 6019 project says yeah we're not
going to look at american history
through the lens of
all these wonderful great
accomplishments from george washington
and thomas jefferson
and all the great stuff america's done
in the world and all the brilliant
reasoning
and and the wonderful acts that brought
america into existence we're only going
to focus on the bad stuff
and so we're going to hold to
consequence some of the greatest men who
have ever walked the earth
and we're going to let vicious people
get off the hook
that's the art that's what all of this
talk about systemic racism
all this is about is reframing the
narrative
so that some of the some of the greatest
people on earth george washington
right are held to account for all the
worst things they've ever
done and people other sorts of people
who are in favor
groups never get held to consequence at
all for the bad things that they've done
lindsey graham was asked about this on
on chris wallace's morning show
is there systemic racism in the united
states
his answer an excellent answer of course
not
senator is there systemic racism
in this country in policing and in other
institutions
no not in my opinion we just elected a
two-term
african-american president the vice
president is of african-american indian
descent
so our systems are not racist america is
not a racist country
within every society you have bad actors
the chauvin trial
was a just result what's happening in
ohio
where the police officer had to use
deadly force to prevent a young girl
from being stabbed to death
is a different situation in my view so
this attack on police and policing
reform the police yes call them all
racists no
you know america is a work in progress
but best
best place on the planet and joe biden
spends a lot of time running the place
down i wish you'd stop it
much of the talk about systemic racism
is explicitly
not is designed explicitly so that
people are not held to consequence for
their actions
because according to the systemic racism
argument
only straight white men who know that
they're men
have any agency whatsoever so they have
to be held to account
the cops good example somehow even if
they're a black cop or a hispanic cop
somehow it's still part of the white
supremacy system cops
held to account all the time they have
to wear body cameras even when they
engage in a just killing like this
officer in the
makia bryant case he's going to have his
life ruined he's going to have lebron
james say you're next he's going to be
doxxed he's going to
face all sorts of consequences but what
about everyone else
what about people who are committing
crimes well no they're only committing
crimes because of
systemic racism the systemic racism made
me do it
what about people who are not taking
care of their families and their
communities
the systemic racism made me do it johnny
where's your homework oh the systemic
racism ain't my homework
that's where it is it's it's not
designed for accountability to use the
fashionable word
it's designed to allow people to evade
consequences
now if you have a gripe if you can even
contrive some some sort of gripe or some
complaint
you can get away with basically anything
which is why people always want to keep
grievance at the forefront of one's mind
the oscars were the other night you
didn't watch i didn't either
nobody did there was an award given out
for the best live-action short film not
not exactly
the most prestigious category here but
the winner if
you were to win an oscar for anything
including best live action short film
and these are people
the ones who are working in the short
films usually are not the
superstars here right these are people
who've been working in obscurity in
hollywood
for a long time they finally their work
of art that they've created gets the
the industry's highest honor what would
you probably go up there and say
gosh thank you i'm so honored
what a privilege it is to be here you'd
either do that or
or you would go whine about police
killings or whatever
today the police will kill three people
and tomorrow the police will kill three
people
and the day after that the police will
kill three people because
on average the police in america every
day kill three people
which amounts to about a thousand people
a year
and those people happen to
disproportionately black people
and you know james baldwin once said
the most despicable thing a person can
be is indifferent to other people's pain
and so i just ask that you please not be
indifferent
please don't be indifferent to our pain
the most despicable thing that a person
can be is indifferent to
other people's pain like this guy
like this guy who's spouting off and
saying every day the police kill three
people
who are the police killing their kid
they're killing largely black people not
most people largely black people
okay what sort of black people he
doesn't say that
the vast vast vast vast vast vast vast
majority of these police involved
killings
are justified the cops are killing
bad guys who are committing crimes
but you're being insensible to the
suffering of others
what about the suffering of the victims
of those crimes what about them
this guy is doing exactly what he's
accusing others of doing
when he is defending criminals here i'll
give you another another
slogan that you can lump in with your
james baldwin slogan this one from adam
smith
mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent we just saw a clear example of
this
in san francisco
a seven-month-old baby is dead in san
francisco
because the district attorney refused to
do his job
because the narrative that now exists is
that any use of police force
is evil and wrong that that
going after criminals is somehow unjust
because the criminals they didn't choose
to become criminals
they're just it's the systemic racist
injustice patriarchy white supremacy
toxic it's everybody's fault but their
own
you know now thank goodness we're living
in a consequence culture
as lavar burton says and that and in
this consequence culture
all the criminals get to go free even
the republicans are endorsing this kind
of nonsense
it was it was the most misguided action
of the trump campaign or of the trump
administration rather
i thought trump did such great stuff
huge fan of the president
former president now i guess i have to
say but
he focused so much time and energy on
what on springing people out of the
clink
why why would we do that when when did
republicans
become the party of springing criminals
out of the clink you know what happens
when you spread
spring criminals from the clink more
people suffer
chase a boudin i don't know how to
pronounce this guy's name
he is a radical district attorney in san
francisco
elected not that long ago jsa boudin
with his lax policies allowed
a guy with a long rap sheet to get out
of the clink
he was already booked on domestic
violence but hey
come you know it's just not fair because
disproportionately men of certain
communities are
targeted the the argument is that black
men are targeted it
in fact criminals are being targeted by
the criminal justice system if there's
some overlap there that's a coincidence
i guess
that's not not the primary motivator so
okay you let the guy out on all these
cockamamie racial theories what happens
kills a seven month old kid
where is the consequence for that guy
okay now
now he'll go back to jail i hope i guess
where's the accountability where's the
justice where are the crocodile tears
from the oscars stage
what about this compassionate wonderful
district attorney
for prison reform we do need prison
reform in this country we need to put
more criminals in prison for longer
and they need to face stiffer
consequences i don't think that anybody
can look around
at the last year and a half as the
country is going up
cities being torched every other night
and say you know you know the problem in
this country
we don't have enough criminals on the
streets we need to let
criminals out of prison i don't think so
i don't think that's the problem
the oscars however were not all bad and
not everyone
made these stupid speeches like this
short film guy tyler perry very very
successful filmmaker
came out and made an important point i
felt which is
you shouldn't judge a book by its cover
and we shouldn't vilify people
on the basis of their race or even
even if they're cops my mother taught me
to refuse
hate she taught me to refuse blanket
judgment
and in this time and with all of the
internet and social media and algorithms
and everything that wants us to
think a certain way the 24-hour news
cycle it is my hope
that all of us would teach our kids and
not only to remember just
refuse hate don't hate anybody i i
refuse to hate someone because they are
mexican or because they are black or
white
or lbgtq i refuse to hate someone
because they are a police officer
i refuse to hate someone because they
are asian
i would hope that we would refuse hate
and i want to take this gene herschel
humanitarian award
and dedicate it to anyone who wants to
stand in the middle
no matter what's around the wall stand
in the middle because that's where
healing happens
that's where conversation happens that's
where change happens it happens in the
middle
so anyone who wants to meet me in the
middle to refuse hate
to refuse blanket judgment and to help
lift someone's feet off the ground this
one is for you too
[Music]
basically a good speech there are
three kinds of oscar speeches one is
the typical leftist you whine about
everything
the second type of oscar speech is the
one where you
say nice political things and you take
the temperature down a little bit
then the third kind of austria speech is
where you thank the academy for
recognizing your artistic work and
really all the oscar speeches should
just be that third one
but i guess that's out the window now i
guess people don't really do that very
much anymore
so if you're gonna have to deal with a
political speech anyway i guess we want
one
that says what tyler perry said tyler
perry notice how clever this is
he i don't think tyler perry is any
particularly conservative yet doesn't
present himself that way
but he goes out there he says refuse
hate it's kind of this
slogany bumper-stickery line
okay refuse hate refuse hate against
mexicans okay
yeah i know everyone's really harsh on
the mexicans right refuse hate against
black people yeah
right we're living in a white
supremacist country right no of course
everyone hates black people right
refuse hate against white people well
that's interesting because we
live in a culture right now where it's
the only socially acceptable form of
racism
is against white people tyler perry
calling that out refuse hate against
police officers whoa that's interesting
now we are basically told that if you
don't come out and hate cops
that you're somehow a white supremacist
so that's a very interesting line
refuse hate against asian people we have
enshrined in our law discrimination
against asians
and whites in the form of affirmative
action that's interesting
he's slipping these very important
things in here is actually a pretty
productive speech i think
but the best speech of the night the one
you know this is a really tailored down
oscar because no nobody was watching
we'll get to that in a second this is a
really tailored down film here
but in this small room a musician named
john
batiste never heard of him he won an
award
for pixar's soul and this guy got up
there
and he gave the best oscar speech i have
heard in years
man you know what's deep is is that um
god gave us 12 notes
it's the same 12 notes duke ellington
had
it's the same 12 nina simone
and all the nominees i just want to
first point out that every gift is
special
every contribution with music that comes
from the divine
into the instruments into the film
into the minds and hearts and souls of
of
every person who hears it the stories
that happen when you
listen to it and watch it and the
stories you share the moments you create
the memories you make
man it's just so incredibly special and
and and i just want to first recognize
the nominees
and say that i'm i'm incredibly i'm
speaking for all of us
we are incredibly humbled and grateful
to the academy
for this recognition and i'm just
thankful to god for those 12
notes man that's so dope i love that
line
i'm i'm just so grateful to god for
those 12 notes man that's so
dope it is it is that's the right answer
that's that's and it's not false modesty
by the way i was talking about this
with tim poole and and uh
the whole show the other night false
modesty is not the same as humility
false modesty is another form of pride
so when people refuse to take a
compliment that's
very often false modesty or
you know when they make a big big deal
about getting a compliment that's a form
of false modesty
true humility though is the sincere
and totally justified acknowledgement
that you are not totally responsible for
your
accomplishments you're not because
you're not responsible for your own life
you did not choose to be born into this
world you did not create your own life
your life is a gift from god
your inborn talents are a gift from god
even the things you work at even the
ways you cultivate those talents and
nurture them and express them
are dire derived from god your work
ethic
your energy the food of this world the
coffee that you drink to give you energy
all of that is a gift and you work in
accordance with that grace
or you don't you can reject it too but
ultimately
you've got to just say well thank god
for all this stuff right if
you're being really humble and really
honest with yourself
that's what you would do that that would
be a great consequence culture
to use levar burton's phrase if we were
to acknowledge
that all these great things in life that
we want to take credit for
they're not really ours all these bad
things in life that we do
they are our fault when we reject the
free gifts that we have been given
because of this fallen world that we're
living in and because of our
compromised and corrupted free will that
would be a real consequence culture but
what we're seeing right now
is that the opposite of that what we're
seeing right now is
we're we're pretending that we deserve
all the wonderful things in life and the
minute that
something doesn't go our way we complain
and we say this is
a grievance and we are victims and
things are being taken away from us
because of the
the patriarchy or the white supremacy or
the whatever
and then we refuse to take
responsibility we refuse to face
consequences for the evil things that we
do
a world in which you can go out and stab
somebody and then
if you are in any way held to account
for that
you complain and say that's unjust
i'm all for a consequence culture what
we're living in right now is the total
opposite of that
ben is going to be talking about some
political consequences right now in the
redistricting
and in the addition of of congressional
seats that's
actually going better for republicans
than for democrats go check that out
also
join us tomorrow for a special episode
of backstage where we will be watching
joe biden's first congressional speech
live apparently this is invite only
we will be giving our expert genius
analysis in real time
and as joe biden daughters along there
we're going to be drinking a lot of
whiskey so the analysis is going to get
more and more expert
throughout the night make sure to go
check that out streams tomorrow at 8 30
eastern
7 30 central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel
the daily wire channel also another
excellent high energy episode of canvas
coming at you this friday
candace is going to be talking to dave
rubin they're going to be talking about
all sorts of stuff especially what's
going on in california
because gavin newsom is officially being
recalled and he's running against
caitlyn jenner because we are living in
a very strange world
candace streams on friday 9 pm eastern 8
pm central only at daily wire get 25
off with a new membership and code
candace at dailywire.com subscribe we'll
be right back with a lot more
how do we come back from the political
brink you've got blm
torching the country and defending kids
stabbing other kids
just to own the cops calls for
abolishing the police
entirely and now the republican standard
bearer at least in
in california is a man who thinks that
he's a woman we have
really something has gone wrong in our
political world
do you know who has the answer one of
the few politicians with crossover
appeal in this country
tulsi gabbard who says hey guys chill
out
hang loose and just embrace the spirit
of aloha my dear friends my fellow
americans
please please let us stop the
racialization of
everyone and everything it's racialism
we are all children of god and are
therefore family
in the truest sense no matter our race
or ethnicity
this is aloha and this is what our
country and the world need
the mainstream propaganda media and
politicians they want us
to constantly focus on our skin color
and the skin color of others
because it helps them politically or
financially
aloha means respect and love
for others it's what enables us to see
beyond our skin color
and see the soul the person within
so let's do our best to cultivate this
aloha in our hearts
and see and treat others through this
prism of love
not through the prism of race and
ethnicity
please let us not allow ourselves to be
led down this
dark and divisive path of racialism
and hate love this absolutely brilliant
what most people are going to hear is
this sort of platitudinous thing about
you know it's just about aloha just
chill out and pop a coconut you know and
have a few drinks
it's cool man we're all we're all people
let's just sing kumbaya
that's not what she's saying she's got a
little bit of that because she's a
politician
but what she's saying is more specific
and more insightful
she says a lot of people
in this country who are in very powerful
positions
have a financial and political stake in
keeping us divided
especially on this fault line of race
she's saying that the establishment
which doesn't like her any more than
they like donald trump actually they're
in different political parties
but the liberal establishment the blob
the corporations
at you know the multinationals the
administrative state
the sort of permanent government the
big tech sector all of these the things
that all work in tandem
don't like tulsi gabbard because she
contradicts their narrative
and she's saying those guys have a real
incentive
to keep you all divided up so they can
maintain
their grip on power it
is just like what amazon does for
instance
when various local amazon worker groups
want to unionize
you've seen some memos come out about
this amazon will always go in and find
ways to get them to hate each other
and they and it's not just amazon big
companies have been doing this for a
long time
they'll go in and figure out the fault
lines in the company among the workers
so that the workers don't unionize and
then once they get
all the workers to hate each other the
big corporation gets to maintain power
the left has has recognized this for a
long time and the right
for a long time especially when the
right was shilling for big corporations
refused to acknowledge it but this is
true this is just what this is a very
basic
political strategy and it's obviously
what's happening right now
and it does account i think for a lot of
the focus on these physical
characteristics
notice what she says here she says we're
all children of god
we're told to think in a racial way
primarily but we're all children of god
what she's saying here as a matter of
philosophy
is we're told to think about the
physical
but actually we have something that
binds us at a metaphysical level this is
by the way
why christians regardless of their views
on evolution
or the origins of mankind
the church has always insisted upon the
descent of the human race
from two parents regardless of how that
all came to be
human beings must descend from these two
parents it's called monogenism
because that that accounts for our human
dignity and our human solidarity
how we are made in the image of god we
all have this common link
all the way back tulsi gabbard pointing
that out really
really good stuff beneath all of the
lines you've heard about how we should
all get along that key the propaganda
media
that's what you've got to be on your
guard against people don't like it
people don't like
the messages that we're being told by
the establishment media right now
however they continue to do it the
numbers are in from the oscars
this was the lowest rated oscars ever
at not the lowest rated oscars in the
last five or 10 years
ever the total viewers dropped
58 percent year over year
so just from last year but last year was
also a record low
so this is an absolute cratering an
absolute collapse
last year you had 23.6 million people
tuned into the oscars
this year 9.85 million
fewer than 10 million for the first time
ever and in the key demographic 18 to 49
these are the people who are going out
and buying stuff
a decline of 64
15 years ago michael moore got up and
gave a political speech at the oscars
bashing george bush
and he got booed he was actually booed
even by the hollywood liberals
because that sort of thing was frowned
upon the oscars have
had political moments for a long time
but they were few and far between
this really began in the 70s when marlon
brando did not show up to accept his
oscar
and he sent a woman who was part indian
to give us give a speech protesting
the treatment of indians in hollywood
sachin little feather take a listen
my name is sashim littlefeather i'm
apache
and i'm president of the national native
american affirmative image committee
i'm representing marlon brando this
evening and he has asked me to tell you
in a very long speech which i cannot
share with you presently
because of time but i will be glad to
share with the press
afterwards that he very regretfully
cannot accept this very generous
award and the reasons for this being
are the treatment of american indians
today
by the film industry excuse me
and on television in movie reruns
and also with recent happenings at
wounded knee
i beg at this time that i have not
intruded
upon this evening and that we will
in the future our hearts and our
understandings
will meet with love and generosity thank
you on behalf of marlon brando
so you can hear in the background when
she goes out and gives the somber speech
about
this relatively minor issue in hollywood
it wasn't even you know
he's not going to take this because he's
protesting the vietnam war
or he's not because he's protesting
whatever some other major
he's protesting the depiction of indians
in hollywood movies in the 70s
what and you hear people bow
and some people applaud and some people
boo and that seems about right
it's gotten so much worse though now
nobody would boo that speech
now you'd have to wow oh wow that's so
beautiful
every speech has to be say chin liter
little feather now nobody likes it
the audience is totally going away why
does the left keep this up because they
have the power
we i think like to delude ourselves in
this country and say look
either in the political realm you say
look this is a democracy okay the people
get what they want
democracy is the theory that the common
people know what they want they deserve
to get it good and hard
as h.l mencken said or this is a
capitalist country okay
the the almighty dollar is what decides
what's going on
if hollywood's pushing a bunch of crazy
propaganda it's because they're going to
make an extra buck out of it
no you get it's both of those are so
reductive
the the political view actually does not
encompass the way that our system of
government works in reality
and the economic view reduces man to a
purely economic
animal which is not what he is that's
not what we are we are much more than
that
what's actually going on here is
something that i document in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now by the way for
pre-order
what's actually going on is that
radicals who had a v
who have very very unpopular views
were able over decades and decades
to attain positions of power and
influence
throughout the culture in this case
specifically in the entertainment
industry
and they've been able to slowly change
the culture
try to get a hold and create a cultural
hegemony
that the common people are still
resisting they're still tuning this
stuff out
but because they have the positions of
power they're not directly
accountable they're not directly
responsible they are not directly held
to consequence
for their craziness eventually
if things train in this direction long
enough and there are no viewers left at
a certain point you think the oscars
are probably going to have to call it
quits but they'll go on for a very long
time
this is not a responsive system right
now
this is a minority of radical ideologues
have taken over huge positions of power
everywhere and they're going to keep
pushing their garbage
whether the common people like it or not
they don't like the common people they
think the common people are deplorable
and irredeemable they tell us that to
our face
when they tell you that you should
believe them
now occasionally some people face some
consequences
for their incompetence and radicalism as
is happening to governor
newsom right now mr nussolini out there
in california
it is official this is relatively
breaking news
gavin newsom will be recalled the
threshold for the recall on the the
signature petition was one million four
hundred ninety five thousand seven
hundred nine signatures that's the
number that they needed to get to
now you might say michael they got two
million way more than two million
signatures so he was obviously going to
be recalled no because what happens in
politics is then you go in
and you take out signatures that you can
say oh no that address wasn't right that
signature doesn't look right that person
moved so you take them all out and what
what newson was hoping was that
he could disqualify enough signatures
that he wouldn't even have to face the
recall
that's long gone he's now at one million
six hundred twenty six thousand forty
two signatures it's going to go up and
up
from there so this guy is officially
getting
recalled he might survive it
the reason he might survive it is that
the recall process is set up
to favor the incumbent what's going to
happen is there's going to be one
question
on the ballot because even though he's
being recalled you still have to answer
the ballot measure
should governor newsom lose his job and
if the majority of people say yes then
they will look at the answers to the
next question which is who should
replace him there are going to be 7
zillion candidates
so the only way that the republicans are
going to have a chance is if they
solidify around a
canada now as of now at least in the
media the leading candidate
is caitlyn jenner and we talked
yesterday on this show
can a conservative go in for caitlyn
on the one hand his policies will be
better than newsomes
on the other hand will be mainstreaming
transgenderism
that would be absolute death for any
sort of conservative movement
and you know that misguided
conservatives are going to start
parroting stupid things like
you know democrats they're the real
transphobes oh we're totally cool with
men putting on dresses and pretending to
be women
so how do you do this i was speaking to
some friends of mine last night i said
is there any way for a conservative to
get behind caitlyn
and they made it somewhat i'm not sure
that i'm totally persuaded by this yet
but they did make a somewhat compelling
case that the only way to do it
is if you had a group called
conservatives for bruce
conservatives for bruce that insisted in
all cases
to refer to him as him and probably just
to call him bruce
because the caitlyn thing is very
confusing
what you would need is a a real
assurance
that caitlyn jenner bruce jenner
was not going to push gender ideology
on conservatives and on the people and
as far as i can tell the only way to do
that
while still letting him prance around in
dresses or whatever he wants to do
whatever makes him
feel more more like how he wants to feel
on the inside
is if he drops the female pronouns and
frankly if he goes back to his old name
could could a guy vote for could a
conservative
vote for bruce jenner if bruce jenner
has this sort of strange
sexual desire yeah maybe
maybe but could a conservative vote for
caitlyn who insists on going by she
and who insists on abolishing same-sex
bathrooms i don't think so i think that
would be very
very difficult so if you're in that
world where caitlyn jenner or caitlyn
she is the leading republican candidate
then probably
newsom is going to survive that and will
not be held
to account
the people who are in power are very
clever they're very crafty
who's the most powerful politician in
the country right now
this should be a simple question if you
hesitated you haven't been paying enough
attention
it's not gavin newsom it's not certainly
not joe biden
it's not kamala harris come on
it's a very easy answer the most
powerful politician in the country is dr
fauci
he he's one of the most powerful
politicians in the history of this
country
he has no democratic accountability
presidents come and go he's worked for
five of them he always stays
in his position of power he is almost
single-handedly crafting national policy
right now
he's he's been doing that from the trump
administration he's doing that now in
the biden administration
and even fauci knows even fauci knows
that he's got to be sort of clever about
this
because his power is not totally
unlimited
dr fauci has come he's been
ruling with an iron fist now for
over a year but he went on one of the
sunday shows on
on abc and
he was asked hold okay come on we're
over a year into this now
do people still need to wear the masks
all the time they even need to wear the
masks outdoors
factory said well you know look maybe
maybe we can negotiate here
you know i don't want to get ahead of
them george but i think it's pretty
common sense now that
outdoor risk is really really quite low
particularly
i mean if you were a vaccinated person
wearing a
wearing a mask outdoors i mean obviously
the risk is minuscule what i believe
you're going to be hearing with the
country
is going to be going to be hearing soon
is updated
guidelines from the cdc the cdc
is a science based organization they
don't want to make any guidelines unless
they look at the data and the data backs
it up
but when you look around at the common
sense situation obviously
the risk is really very low particularly
if you're vaccinated
okay so now we have i think this is the
17th
mask position from dr vauchi
remember the first position was masks
are dumb and stupid and they don't do
anything and you shouldn't wear one even
at the height of a pandemic
it's not going to maybe it will block a
driplet but it'll be bad because you'll
touch your face so do not wear the mask
sheep
then he changes his position and he says
actually masks are really good they're
necessary you have to wear the masks
i only told you that you shouldn't wear
the masks because i wanted to save them
for the nurses
okay then we got to wear double masks
now we don't need to wear masks outside
soon
maybe what's going on here fauci is not
giving a scientific proclamation
he is a very very adept and clever
politician
who is navigating the political waters
as best he can and trying to hold on to
power
there is no simple answer here when
people
when people tell you that the answer in
politics is clear
it's so clear what what is what to do
i'm reminded of a saying of of my priest
father father rutler where he says
shallows
are clear shallow thinking is clear
complicated things deep things true
things are profound they're murky
they're a little
trickier someone came in and said
look advanced calculus is clear you say
well i don't know if it is
i think it's pretty advanced actually
it's sort of complicated
that same thing here if we want to take
power back from these people if we want
to hold these people
to consequence we're going to have to be
clever and crafty and we
we have to ditch the old bumper sticker
slogans
this is much more complicated than
come on just free speech free speech
absolutism
uh just read the constitution uh just go
back to the 1780s that's not
it's not a serious answer that is not
going to wrest
power back from these people we're going
to have to be cleverer than that
we are seeing some consequences right
now in our legal system
consequences of the past year and a half
more than that where the the liberal
establishment has told us that cops are
evil racist terrible people and any time
they do their job
and enforce the law they could have
their lives ruined and end up in the
clink for
for life right now people are quitting
the nypd in droves
uh there is a 75 increase
year over year in the number of cops
retiring
quitting their jobs 75 percent increase
year over year
amounting to 15 of the total number of
officers on the force
some people are saying good good you
know the left wants to abolish the
police fine
get the police out of their crappy
neighborhoods and see how they like it
good give them what they want democracy
is the theory that the people know what
they want deserve to get it good and
hard
i don't think that's the right idea i
don't think we should cede this ground i
don't think we should allow the left to
abolish the police i don't think
we shouldn't cede any of that at all
i think that is the same failed strategy
that we have been practicing for years
and years and years
it's that same strategy of forget about
politics only focus on the culture
it's that same failed strategy of hey
look i don't care what you say or do
just don't make me pay for it i'm for
freedom in the abstract
totally a historical understanding of
freedom that has no basis in the actual
american tradition
founding fathers would find it
completely foreign
no we need to get involved we need to
say no you want to abolish the police
we're going to double the police and
we're going to send them into your
neighborhoods and you're going to call
us
sexist and racist and this is to i don't
care we're going to enforce the law
we're going to force our
traditional american standards okay
we're going to enforce
the good and the true and the beautiful
and not the
bad and the wicked and the ugly and the
unjust and the false we're going to
actually stand for a substantive message
here which brings me to
that mma fight between the ladies
that happened this weekend this was the
fight between rose namahunas
and zhang wylie at the ufc i didn't
watch this
i we did cover it on the show a couple
weeks ago because there was this great
moment before the fight
where rose namahuna said look i'd rather
be dead than red
i stand for the west i stand for the
tradition of freedom that we have here
i don't like communist china i don't
stand for that
there's a real ideological battle going
on and i stand on the side of freedom
wow love that that's great totally for
that
but i did not watch the fight i had no
desire to watch the fight
i don't intend ever to watch one of
these fights i guess i'm glad that the
freedom girl won
that's good namahunis beat the other
girl she was very happy about that good
for her
we should not be watching women beat
each other up that is
just wrong that's just disordered a
healthy society doesn't do that
hate to be a wet blanket hate to be a
fuddy duddy here
but i don't want to watch a woman get
her head beaten in
that's weird that's a that's a perverse
thing people shouldn't be doing that
but michael come on you know they can do
it they're really strong they are really
strong i bet i bet
actually some of them could beat me up
even though men are physically much
stronger than women these are
pretty tough ladies okay i'm not
doubting that at all but it's still
wrong and when when the right goes in on
this stuff and says oh come on
whatever they want to do if they want to
do it that's cool just don't make me do
it
when the right goes in on this we give
up the whole game
no women should not be beating each
other up in public
that's whether it's in sport or whether
it's in the streets or wherever
that is wrong we're giving away the
whole we're giving we might as well vote
for caitlyn
we're giving away the whole we might as
well use the pronouns if we're saying
that there's no difference
between men and women no we have to
stand for something more guys we've got
to stand for something more
than just do whatever you want we are
going to live in a consequence culture
levar burton is absolutely right but
what are the consequences going to be
what what is the standard going to be
against which we are judged i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show red
and purple states gain congressional
seats as blue states lose population
the anti-cop movement continues to gain
steam and we discuss the single worst
example of woke mob targeting i've ever
seen
that's today on the bench shapiro show
give it a listen